once again good day good evening
wherever you are joining us today
this is a free webinar into our program
titled introduction to big data
bioinformatics
my name is aditya abushadi
i'll be one of the hospitals and mentors
in this program
today we would like to
give you
inwards into the program
into i like to talk about the program's
levels program features
and how to
get
but participants
registered into this program we also
love to talk about prime biotech as a
company
and omix logic as a program
but today we are not the only ones it's
not only prime biotech we are doing this
in conjunction
with
biology solution
right and
in the next few minutes we would like to
invite the ceo of valid solution dr voki
tui
and i said earlier the program mainly is
to introduce you and share with you
details
about this upcoming program
and explain how the training resources
we discussed today will be used in the
upcoming
beginner program
i hope everyone can see my screen
yes
thank you very much
so
pine biotech was founded
by expert mathematicians and people with
expertise
in the field of
biology in the field of mathematics and
in the field of computational
science starting with dr alfred tuber
from the toba medical institute in
israel
and
since then paul batek has been working
with a whole lot of
schools more than schools in more than
100 countries
to
teach them about bioinformatics
from the basics
so they were collaborating with the
number of academic justices
around the world and they have
participated in congress evaluation
curriculum review
project designs
so as a result of this omix logic
programs have been totally evaluated and
are known to lead to
excellent outcomes importantly
the programs are designed to support
students
and beginners with minimum performance
background
including biology
biomedical studies majors as well as
faculties interested in bioinformatics
data science
and biomedical research
part of these countries is nigeria and
africa generally where
back starting as early as 2019. com pine
belted with the omega programs have
involved nigerian faculties one of one
of our partners will be working with
this program is doctor vocatoi the ceo
of bollard solutions
dr volkey are you there i would love how
to introduce yourself
and talk a bit about our experience with
point about it
yes good afternoon
good afternoon
can you hear me yes we can
all right
good afternoon everyone thank you
i would like to welcome you all to this
free webinar
my name is dr tui
and as
dr aditya has said i'm the founder and
ceo of biologic support services here in
nigeria
biologics has pioneered several
trainings
in molecular biology and bioinformatics
with the aim of building required skill
and capacity
for the imaging about technology
industry here in nigeria
i have benefited immensely from the
omics logic training
and in
2000 year 2000
biologics has partnered with
prime biotech in offering
the first
big biportis big data training here
virtual training
for for nigeria
so it's well known that biology is now a
data science
and um
we are no longer
dealing with single cells
and as we
generate more
sequence data through ngs sequencing
there's therefore an increasing need
to know how we would analyze this ever
increasing
data
in order for us to arrive at outcomes
that will be of immense benefits
in disease diagnosis
treatment selection
and in agriculture
so one of the key aspects of this
training will be engaging by
participants
in basic translational
research projects
for instance you'll be able to learn how
to use multi-opex approaches
to interrogate genomic or transcriptomic
data from cancer cells
so this has the potential of predicting
the phenotypic changes
of cancer cells and their responses
in
different
agents
so i'm sure that this training will be
a new learning curve for many of us here
and it promises to be a rewarding
experience
for the following for for those of us
that would go ahead
and
enroll for the
three-month strength for the yes three
months training i think so thank you
everyone
over to you doctor at the time
thank you very much mom
that is doctor valkyrie she's also one
of the fascinators and one of the
mentors
in this program so we'll be hearing more
from her
so in a nutshell i'll basically just
want to show
what the plan is for this program
what pinebaltec is and what to expect in
this
six weeks long program right as i said
this is part of our omics logic program
and when we talk about omics logic what
exactly is the goal of comics logic
the omex logic goal is to provide
training bioinformatics
to enable independent research that are
guided by mentors and peers
to develop a growing community of
mathematicians
with shared passion
for data-driven research
and
appreciation of citizen science
it's
another goal is also to enable students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology
in life science and data science
what our programs we have
our plans to have between five to six
interactive sessions starting from next
week wednesday november 24
where we talk about introduction to big
data in biology
then subsequently the
second to six programs we'll talk about
genomics introduction to genomics
introduction to transgenomics
differential gene expression
drawn to
biomedical static analysis of machine
learning and we plan to end with
introduction to bomb informatics project
right we also introduce you to some
projects before the end
of this program
we have a plethora of local and
international mentors starting with the
ceo and founder of pine belted that's
eliabrutsky followed by dr mohit
mazunder who has a phd in conditional
biology
joined by local mentors myself i'm a
neuropathologist and
equals about our pathologist i'm also a
faculty then with doctor vocate who is
the ceo of borax solution
these local international mentors will
guide us all through
these
six weeks
so again what exactly is what exactly
are we talking about what exactly is
alphabet
what why are we calling it big beta
right
biology is rapidly acquiring the
character of data science
because billions of data points on genes
proteins and other molecules
are compiled in large files and have
been systematically studied so analyzing
this data will lead to more knowledge
more understanding about living
organisms and we can use this knowledge
to
assist or understand human health about
technology crops and livestock so this
course is just to give an overview
of this bioinformatics and the
application of bioinformatics for
students as i said earlier for beginners
and majorly for biologists and
clinicians with this influx of data with
associated methodologies people are now
going into data-driven research which
make bioinformatics for life sciences as
permanent as the emergence of computers
for the tech industry in some years back
biologists clinicians doctors have to
consult
biostatisticians to be able to
understand their data but with
with the advent of technologies
now every clinician
every biologist every life scientist
every medical lab scientist
every methodology
is expected
to be
in fact it can be said that biology
itself is now
in
biology is now in data science right so
there's so many resources out there
and the analysis of these resources and
the data they give us tell us the clear
story that as a scientist as a
researcher as a student in life sciences
he must be capable of not only
understand the science right but you
must also understand data and it was
also have the
opportunity to be able to do research
with
these data
so this program is designed to highlight
the role of big mix data now when we
talk about big data what are we talking
about you know as
as
after the sequencing of the human genome
it is said that the human genome is
about p billion base pairs imagine three
billion biscuits if you want to analyze
this information you want to glean
knowledge into this information you
cannot do this by mere mean median by t
test by simple
specific analysis right this is big data
you need
advanced
statistics to be able to understand this
and this data
understanding this data is now shaping
modern biomedical innovation where the
molecular data and analysis
is being used for precision diagnostics
big data integration
and the machine learning are
transforming personalization of
treatment selection
concocted with innovative algorithms
that now allow for unprecedented
capabilities
with drug discoveries and
design of large molecules and drug
purposes we all know that with the
advent of kovid before it takes 20 to 30
years before a drug is designed or
scenes have manufactured but with the
advent of artificial intelligence and
machine learning
they all take up didn't take us up to a
year or two before we could get
drugs that are that are working actively
for covered that's one of the essence of
bioinformatics
big data and chemicals so at this point
i would like to post
and ask if there any questions
you can put in the chat or you cannot
reach yourself and ask
any questions
please can you hear me
yes yes it's very
okay so i should assume there are no
questions for now
hello hello i can hear you sir yes sir
no question
no question for your hand okay okay
from my end
society thank you very much for that
question
thank you very much for that question so
far
i can simply say
that more than any other aspect of
healthcare
pharmaceutical industries are the ones
that are most gaining from it right
imagine
almost five billion dollars of drugs
i've been spending money on common drugs
on comments about it
but if you want if you're a pharmacist
or you're from a school line you
understand that pharmacodynamics and
pharmacokinetics work differently on
different state of people right those of
you
are this really that will work for me
might not be because that work for you
and it's dependent on a lot of genetic
factors imagine
we are able to understand the genetic
makeup of each person of each individual
and because of that knowledge you're
able to tailor a drug
only for that individual
how how lovely would that be the implies
i don't waste money buying a pizza of
drugs i just need to buy one that i know
has been tailored for me that is what we
call personalized medicine that's one
too you're not you if pharmacy or
informatica science you also understand
that before the invention of any joke it
takes years
yes before you can finally get a drug
that works
successfully for a condition but now we
the advent of bioinformatics
people are going into what we call chemo
informatics where you can begin to
design drugs you just down your laptop
you design drugs
that work for each chemicals right and
with that you can easily gets a certain
job for this condition
in in in years not decades not only that
it has also assisted it's also assisting
what we're calling drug hypocrisy
which was very evident in the covet
pandemic imagine how many above drugs
that are supposed to be used for other
diseases are now being used for coveting
that's drug processing right
bioinformatics is the key to that
bioinformatics opens up to that it opens
the
open logic genomics you understand
somewhat you understand an individual's
genomics and you tell a drug
for that individual personalized
medicine
however this pleasure
he's presently not playing a
a cogent role in assisting treatment
molecular diagnosis and position
medicine
so
in a bit we were talking about big big
data
what exactly are these weeks
and how what what exactly do they mean
right this is one of the things we talk
about in this program we'll start with
genomics
which is different from genetics usually
when we talk about genetics we're
talking about study of ap
a gene or a pair of genes or some number
of genes
to study them and see how
they work probably their transition to
protein or in his information when we
talk about genomics we're talking about
the all
complete three billion pairs of the
human body
we're talking about three billion base
pairs
how to understand pre these two billion
base pairs how to glean information from
it and how to explain is that this
condition successability to an infection
or molecular pathogenesis of cancers
right so this is this is a field that
can assist in understanding
why is mr a
to cancer a and why would that be
susceptible to cancer b for a lot of
years
scientists and clinicians actually
thought breast cancer was just one
cancer it was what cancer was
got bit of
bioinformatics they were not able to
explain that when we said breast cancer
we're actually talking about four or
five variants
of different cancers that could affect
the breast this is the one of the
advantages of
bioinformatics also there's also a thing
known as transcriptomics which will talk
about gene expression i'm sure you know
that every cell in human body
consists of the same gene information
meaning the cells in your head the cells
in your leg the cells in your abdomen
they consist entirely of the same sort
of information then the question is
why are cells
in the head
why are they expressing a why are the
cells in the leg why are they expressing
other things right this is what we call
gene expression
this is
and that's what we call transitions
understanding of this who let us gain
information about despite the fact that
each cell contains the same information
how comes some genes
some proteins i expect somewhere while
others i experience elsewhere we can
also use this to understand tumors or to
more conditions right you can you can
take something from a tissue
and take sample from normal cell and
then compare what genes are being
expressed by this tumor condition
that are not expressed in normal genes
and from this you can this he can
actually glean information about the
genes that are involved in the
nucleophile genesis or cancerogenesis
and you can then decide on getting drugs
to either
kill or drugs for this condition and so
these are the other things are like the
other omics like epigenetic epigenomics
like metagenomics you know metagenomics
is the one that i feel
it's very critical
for microbiologists you will know that
with culture
scientists still don't know
about 75 percent or 80 percent of
microorganisms we have
both in our body and the environment
because culture us is a lot of
limitations but with metagenomics they
can
gather or adequately
analyze almost 95 percent of the
microorganisms and not only that we can
also see the function of the
microorganisms their effects on the on
the human body whether in the gut
whether in the brain whether in your
cavity or their effect
on the environment
right and so that field is known as
microbiome or metagenomics so these are
the
motion mix data we'll talk about who one
of our sessions will be on
mic on metagenomics they're not only
doing nothing we also need to also learn
and talk about what are so what are some
of the challenges when we're analyzing
this
oh mix data so this online program as i
said earlier i will start
next wednesday november 24th and we'll
cover some of
the important technologies and the
applications in today's world the
participants were able to access
informatic resources along
with expert and mental support to get
help with learning process that will be
available for
five to six weeks of this program
right and also be able to learn how to
get information from
[Music]
biological
data
so briefly
let me check their questions
oh
operational genomics the
for most of us we know that especially
with an african we work between ten and
four so all our programs start at 4 30
p.m
right and usually last for 90 minutes by
six will be done now this program is
actually an iboot program
our session our live sessions will be
majorly focused on particularly
right
when i'm talking you understand that
pine bar tech actually has a couple of
educational resources right one of them
is just educational resources where you
go to and learn important concepts
important terminology right then the
path hands-on
who do the path on on
during our live sessions so he's not
asking we'll do everything live sessions
what we do majorly
apart from amazon so we'll give you a
week we'll give you assignments
we'll give you courses to read during
the week they will come here wednesday
and talk about and for some that
actually miss some sessions all our
sessions
will be recorded
like this is already because all our
sessions recorded and
each session video will be sent to
register
right not only that that means we have
local international mentors we have
whatsapp groups we have slack channels
where you can always ask questions i'm
one of the mentors and trust me you can
call me at any time any time of the day
right so ask questions about the session
really you don't understand so that way
you won't miss anything per se
i hope i've been able to
answer that question
so i said earlier
not only are we going to teach you about
resources but also open you up to
project mathematic projects on our
website we have twitter data set for
practice we'll be using
to tell you some of some of the
publications while we are getting this
data set for example there's the middle
position treatment of breast cancer
which was featured in genome download in
2013 the publisher is very interesting
because the authors assembled a
data set of 50 different breast cancers
cell lines that represent all the
spectrum of breast cancer durations they
analyzed it they did imagine expression
and they were able to also get drugs
that were able to treat different types
of breast cancers because i said earlier
breast cancer is not just one cancer
it's different types of cancer so drugs
that were treated in one we're not
treating others so they were able to get
drugs that were specific for each
breast cancer we also talk about that
process
so right now i would love to pause a bit
so that's more questions if there are no
questions i would love to
let us join me while i log in to our
first edition of resources the learn
community.com
i will be able to register
and create our profile are there any
questions before i do that
any questions i have a question hello
can i ask you a question
um i'm just getting a sense that this
platform is all on the website you guys
don't train on uh tools within or
outside of the of the platform no no no
no no no
when we'll get there man
i will introduce you to
our main our main pipeline tool right
the
t-bow server
where you have all
biologic algorithms if you are familiar
with bioinformatics you know
about trimatic about about
first q about fast speed all available
formative tools and not only that also
all machine learning tools right this is
on that platform we'll get there but not
only that
not only are we going to teach you this
we also know that if for you to be
a an advanced bioinformatician you need
to be able to do some programs right i
know that three common programs for
bankruptcy you have out we have python
we have lineups also on our educational
resources we have
out and we have fighter right i will
also take you
through the basics of this program
during this course right you learn how
not you're not going to let our uh as
the app called programmer but you learn
how that is relevant and specifically
for bioinformatics right
so anything reading biopharmatics i can
assure you
you get it within
our educational resources and our
artificial intelligence guided
smart cloud enabled bus server.com
is that okay man
yes
thank you so we are not okay
sorry i have a question yes please sir
okay so um thanks a lot for this program
and sincerely i've been waiting for
something like this here in
in nigeria i mean
it is the hub of
you know miraculous science currently so
i want to know how much is the full
package from
beginner to
advanced so
one can make planning budget you
understand yes so how how much is the
full body then two is is
um
will there be certification
yes
thank you very
are things okay so i'm planning to talk
about right
for this program the the way we planned
it you know we said is this omix logic
program it's a step-by-step
guided mentorship program right we
understand that
people that are something people that
are beginners now some that will be
advanced learners are some that will be
veterans so plan to meet everybody along
the way so we're planning to we are
going to hold a series of programs this
is just the starting point it's more
like for beginners right this is like
the just you for everything right and
this program itself is 45 for this
program but our plan is starting from
next year we plan to hold series of
programs that we can move each person
right from beginner to intermediate to
advanced programs right we'll be
ordering programs
in in batches in series right so that
anybody whatever level you are you can
join us through the program right
probably once in three months or once in
six months or quarterly as as as the
members desire that's that's our plan
jonathan
hello sir
yes i guess
i want to also ask yes
hello hello i can hear you sir
hello
i can hear you i i got your point i want
to also ask
um things like maybe dna sequencing dna
extraction pcr and all of those
gel
electrophoresis um
practices are also
involved because i know the organizers
of this program yeah that um they are
kind of a biological practical place
company so i don't know if they do that
because many of us
we just thought this thing theoretically
we don't know how to use this pcr
machine you know how to sequence a dna
extract sequence and all of that we
we're not we're not giving the practical
insights into it and
i mean we're just giving the theories
and
is bch data and we're not even taught
how to do it i don't know if there's a
program like that that could come up yes
thank you very much sir as i said
we as a company we're actually into
bioinformatics legion the dry lab if
you're familiar everything you do in the
laboratory we call it well right those
pcl
the
sequencing itself the dlt forces flows
sedimentary they're done in laboratory
right
and that's why we partner with senior
biologic solution if they
they also own a series of trading
programs on that right what we are doing
as a company is after pcl where you get
your secrets what do you do with it
right so we are the dry lab aspects of
bioinformatics justin biosolution they
hold a lot of programs and we'll
probably talk about we also talk about
it they will probably
tell you when
and how when they they do all their own
practical sessions but for us we are the
joy of aspect of things our our goal our
goal is
what to do after your sequence your data
right what do you do with it how do you
analyze this data how do you get
information from it for some
pcl is just that beginning right you
only do your cell you get your data what
do you do with that data that you get
after you must have done pcr
what how do you glean information from
that data right so we are the dry lab
aspect of things mobility solutions
various solutions
are they actually cheap their foremost
job is actually on the web level of
things and they also practical training
programs as regards that justin but how
we are okay dr trey the thing is now i
think she wants to
chip in and say what i'll talk about
yes i quite understand where the
gentleman is coming from
so again we see these kind of scenarios
where
many people
still want to have
a more basic understanding of where all
this information is even coming from and
how do we even get there so like dr just
mentioned there is what we call the west
laboratory aspect which is more of
hands-on on how you can
actually
get to your pc pcr and then
your gene of interest that you
you you want to work on and then get it
sequenced okay but what they are talking
about here is more of um
a lot of data that is already available
in a lot of databases based on so much a
lot of research that's taking place
uh
uh especially looking at cancer
cells
both with those that are there in the
resistance or the normal cells and so a
lot of
deep sequencing is done to get you
um data
of a particular sample not only will it
be genomic data but also
data that uh
shows you the transcriptomic or the rna
sequence for that particular condition
as well as if you want to
the proteomic
information in the data form okay and so
that's why it's called big data and so
all of this can be analyzed using the
tools available on the platform
by prime biotech and part of this
training will teach you or show you how
these tools are used and under the
different um
um
[Music]
using the different tools either for
meta genomics or for rna sequencing
you will be able to take you through on
how to use that but for basic
molecular biology skills that perhaps
many of you did not even experience at
you know during your programs esc or
even msc yes biology definitely
organizes trainings hands-on wet lab
trainings to address this gaps and this
is one of the things we do very very
well i hope that helps you
thank you very much
i i hope you understand that sir
hello hello please i need to ask a
question yes mom
thanks for organizing this program it's
actually been an information
please doctor
tell you please can't share a link to
those um
anton training how i can access them
okay so just uh let us have your email
just um alfred will get in touch with
you
give you additional information
okay all right i will type my email in
the chat box yes
all right thank you very much
thank you very much
one of the things we're also planning is
that
because it probably comes with a point
where we
have programs that will start with the
wet lab details that occupy just
mentioned and we'll end the dry lab
details that we are talking about is
bioinformatics so that everything will
be encompassing right yeah these are
things we are
working on and probably early next year
maybe the next day we can make this
happen depending on what exactly the
participants would love to have
so in a nutshell let me just take us
straight to our platform uh you know i
said we have a couple of educational
resources
so
i would love to start with the very
first one
just give me a minute
is can we ask you see my screen
yes we can okay
so i will type the name into the chat
forum now
the website is
learn.orglogic.com
i is already in the chat forum
so this is
our additional resources
here yeah
everything you need to know about
multi-umics you can find on this website
right
it has
so the first thing to do
is
to
open a profile or register with this
platform i hope you can also see the
i'm typing it again
into the chat from lend.omg.com
and
if you are new
if you haven't registered before the
first thing to do is to register you
know click register for free
how many of us are on this website
already
so if you're a new user when you come
here just click on create an account
right if you click an account type in
your name
your email address and the password you
would love to use
not only that you can also log in via
your gmail account or facebook
right so how many of us are here if
you're here please contact once it's a
chat box
are you already on this website
thank you emanella
they give your user already
nice to know
yeah someone finished business with us
yes
if i helped do it because of this
program we'll be able to finish some of
these videos altogether okay somewhere
thanks a lot marcia he's already
good to know so for the ones that have
already registered you can just
sign in straight
right for new users
you gotta sign in now please if you're
having any issues with signing in please
just kind of let me know so i'm already
a user
but i'll
i'll just log into my account
thank you something
so even though
this program itself is a paid program
i'm i'm i'm elected to let you know that
there are a lot of freebies a lot of
free educational resources in fact our
first two courses are entirely free the
only thing you just need to do is to
open
a
sorry i will delete
the website
i'm typing the game
into the chat forum
just click on that link it will take you
straight there
land.onlylogic.com
hxps not http
right
so when you come here
you can see this is my own platform
thank you abubakar
you're calling me on bites
you're the chief
rebecca can you can attest to the fact
that if you wanted to know the
problematic is free because also free so
if you are here
the name you enter will show here this
is my own profile and if i click on
this if you click on your name or your
username whatever you use you can take
it to your profile right and so that
will be able to know ourselves you will
be able to know who you are will be able
to relate with you we usually
after that our profile is updated if you
select the file you can put in your
picture like i have your name can be
here
you can also give us your facebook profi
your facebook profile because we also
love you to follow us on our
on our social media pages and we also
follow you back you can put your link
into these places i cannot give you a
small a small profile for example i i i
was the straw community manager for
meslogic africa i'm one i'm one of the
mentors i said earlier i'm a data
scientist a machine learning exponent
and i'm a pathologist i'm also a faculty
here in bio university i'm actually the
deputy dean of the faculty of dentistry
so there was a small
profile was written in it so once you do
that you update this right and once you
update this everything will
be over yourself so you can learn to
know you can length talk to you and
network with you and once that is done
you can just come here to courses
and where we have a torah of courses
when i say pluto i'm telling you we have
a plethora of courses right and most of
these some of them are paid but
quite a number of them are also free so
the first two courses especially for
beginners now i'll tell you everything
about bioinformatics is the first one is
introduction
you can just type it here introduction
to bioinformatics you see it's coming as
one
if you click on this i can also send you
this link
so i just go straight
to the course
i've typed the link in the chat forum
so when you come to this link this
course gives you
the background of everything you need to
know about informatics right you can say
it has three lessons the first one is
relationship that about formatix it
tells us about the application of both
music's healthcare and transitional
informatics right this is like the most
basics in comics logic we believe in
taking you step by step we are assuming
a beginner will take you like like a
student who like you guide your hands
through the steps of bioinformatics so
that starts with introduction to
bioinformatics when when you are done
with this and somebody asked about
certificate earlier we have different
types of certificates for each course
that you finish you get a certificate
once you are done with these three
lessons and you complete it and you
complete it there will be questions
assignments after one job once you're
donated you get a certificate for this
course
before each course you finish on i'm
sending the number
for each course you finish in our
property you get a certificate
for every program
thank you very much for this program for
example big data informatics one that
does this program we also get a
certificate so there are certificates
for finishing each cost and a
certificate for participation in each
program and for programs certificates
are two types right there is a
classification will cause a little bit
of participation for coming to this
program
there are
it's an exhaustive comprehensive
hands-on program
unfortunately what you do
for each achievement you get you get
points for it so once your points are up
to 3000
you get a certificate of participation
if you don't make up to 3 000 points we
are not going to give you a certificate
but i said it's a practical amazon
program but for some people that are
very good they're very motivated once
you get up to ten thousand points you
get a certificate of excellence you
become an expert so during this program
if you're able to cut three dozen points
you get a certificate for it you know
it's got ten thousand points you're
getting two certificates and that is a
bit of persuasion once again speaking of
excellence this is coupled with
certificate for each course that you're
able to finish right i said earlier the
first course is integration performance
the second one
which also
opens you up to the field of
bioinformatics
is known as bytes and molecules
right
byt yes just type it here and that's
cos2
i also put this in the chat form so you
see
so you can just click this link and
takes you directly to the second course
these two courses as i said earlier are
absolutely free
they are absolutely free you can just do
them to just get an understanding of
the way
our education resources
are
factored or modeled
any questions so far as i said earlier
the two courses bites are molecules
unless they are
free entirely free right you don't need
to be a part of this program before you
can do this but once you're a part of
this program we have access to all the
courses
on these educational resources as i said
earlier we have up to
15 courses
of all material mix we have projects
right projects that have been curated
that have been done you can see these
are projects project topics for people
that have written papers who break down
the tools they use right these are so
this is our project so we also we also
teach us we have access to all
our courses all our programs like i said
earlier
for each activity on this program you
also get points for it
so any questions so far
any questions
let me just go back straight to my
presentation so as i said i've i've i've
shown you the educational resources
platform where you go and get the
learning right you understand the theory
the
the
question okay sir
go ahead sir
okay i want to ask is there any
specification for the kind of laptops
you need because over time i do hear
okay you have to get eight gig ram and
you have to get maybe one terabyte
because the installations you do
might be heavier or something
specifications uh
that that that's a very nice question
sir and that's where when i talk about
our next platform
that's where you you actually understand
why
we are pushing this point out now when i
started learning bioinformatics i have
to start learning
by learning each of these mathematic
tools right meaning you have to do it on
your laptop mathematics is
computationally
intensive right
like i said earlier the human genome is
three billion b pairs right if you want
to download the human reference genome
the last time i downloaded it it was 25
gigabytes
right even if especially you know the
green ninja networkings even if you have
if you have data you know that there is
no there is no likelihood that it will
be
tabulated at any point in time right so
it used to be that to me but the way
prime biotech has gone through going
around it
is that our next
resource i'm talking about it's actually
on the cloud it's cloud-based
meaning
you don't need to store anything on your
system of course you need to have a
document is raising up on the
game okay i i i'll allow you to finish
with this before
okay
so individually
without our next
resources i want to talk about if you're
just trying to do
bioinformatics and competition on your
system
if you actually in the system with a
large hard disk if possibility finally
get right and one terabyte and you need
to have calls that are very fast because
you are dealing with a large number of
data remember this is big data and for
everything you do you have to go through
the processes of
typing them or mapping them to the human
reference gym especially when you're
working with dealing with humans so it
is functional intensity but the way
around that is our next resource i'm
going to talk about the the boss of our
team server is cloud-based right so you
don't need to actually do anything in
your system
everything you're doing is on the cloud
you just
tell the system what you want it to do
right then dump it on it
just now you're not going to do it on
your phone i don't go to the system you
don't need any resources whatsoever any
laptop can do this because the only
thing you're doing is once once you've
created a pipeline once you've told the
server what to do you just load it there
and just wait for it to do its thing
right so because of our t-bow server you
don't actually need any specification of
laptop just a number one laptop the
normal running network and you're fine
hello
okay
yes i just wanted to emphasize um
on the
courses that you spoke about
that is available on the platform for
additional or reinforced learning
so for some of you that already have a
background in molecular biology i mean
that's a plus for you
but it was i would still encourage you
to go through those courses because um
one
you would be required in between at some
point in the training
to use the team bio platform
to execute some assignments using data
that made available
and it would be into
you will find some of those causes of
immense benefits when executing these
assignments so i encourage you to really
take them
seriously at your pace obviously and um
enjoy it while you're doing that and
then that also helps when you come we
come back
for another uh present another meeting
for questions to be asked and then we
can help you with those questions
okay so
and just to help just to reinforce again
on the on the
type of computing you need or data space
everything you're working on in terms of
processing
will be in the cloud so you don't need
any extra space on your computer
all right and you you would you would
you would see that once you start
especially on the tbi platform some of
the processing of the pipelines which is
just the steps involved in you
processing a particular set of data some
of them could take a short time some
could take a little long you know
probably
like up to 30 minutes but essentially
all this data is up in the cloud and so
you don't need any form of extra data
space on your system
just wanted to reinforce that thank you
thank you very much ma
so mr oluwatobi you always know he also
losing opinion
mr nobody are you still there
yes i'm here um
good evening everyone
so thank you for this discussion because
so my question really is
um this program would be enough for you
to
i mean for example i mean internet
nightmare and you know some cps
sometimes and we generate data from our
printing platform and there's background
we do hiv resistance so we use all these
kind of applications that you know just
give it to the application click click
and hold it bring something down and you
don't really know
how it's doing that and all of that like
that one can only do what hiv you can't
do for all diagnosis of some other form
of analysis
um is it are there any limitations to
this particular training like in this
book
you can only work for a particular kind
of research or you can apply to like a
general kind of research antibiotics
stand um setting for mutation searching
for variance i don't know what i'm
saying
yes
i understand
perfectly right you know you said
this is
these are moving forward right and our
platform has all these bioinformatics
tools for example
as
session transaction three will be on
genomics mapping visualization
conveyance calling right you actually if
you are familiar with both somatic tools
you know that when you want to call
where you are when you are doing their
own calling you were talking about some
tools bomb tools we're talking about
bow tie too we're talking
every of them we have them on our
platforms what i want to use is for
metagenomics or infectious diseases what
i want to use for to understand cancers
is that by a second session we actually
visualize
covey data covert sequencing we
visualize ebola
velocity crisis right we we know that
for now it's easier to it's very cheaper
to sequence viral infectious diseases
the last time i tried to get a sequence
for human genome
you can check it it's still 1600
right you can check out him as a day
someone somebody without we have to
probably
import it now
imagine a researcher
and you're already paying 1000
for just one person so if you want to
sequence 50 people you know that's
already all the money for that and you
know especially in africa in nigeria
where most researchers remove research
is cell phone that has a lot of money
right so
what
what our platform is
we also teach you how to get those
sequences you don't need to sequence
them yourself right but even if you
express them yourself on our platform
you can visualize your sequences you can
map your sequences to any reference
genome of your choosing you can
understand you can do variant calling
you can understand mutations right you
can
as i can go further and understand snips
and understand causes either genomic
transformation you can also go ahead
and do what we call differential
expression while you understand the
differences the gene expression of this
so all this it is not related to one
discipline right we've had colleagues
that are microbiologists medical lab
scientists as i said earlier i'm a
clinician i'm a dentist who have one
medical doctors who have
for every aspect of life science not
only that even for machine learning
right on our platform i'm sure it was a
lot of personal
don't forget like inaudible short little
decision tree
like any anything you think about
everything is available on our platform
and you can use it for any of your
research right and as i said one more
thing
yes
okay so um concerning the context i
think i have the computer i mean and i
want to be able to do it on my laptop so
that essentially i'm not really
intending this
i'm done with the content of that and i
need to do it on my laptop i'm not
really depending on the server kind of
because i have some software and i i
don't know if there's position for that
should i i can use my own laptop your
device i think i have the computing
power
you know that's what i'm saying you have
the complete power right we have a
platform that will make it easy but if
you have complete power then most of
these are worn by programs right we'll
teach you another i said there's nothing
you would do on genomics that you can't
do it out or
right also teach you how and python in
case you want to do it yourself on your
own system right not only are you
you can do it with uh
what's it called a t-bar server but if
you also want to do it if you want to
understand the pics of this the
fundamentals of which
and do it by yourself your sister wants
to teach you the basics right now i said
power and python learning is part of
this program we want to introduce you to
it right even some part of linox we
teach you
as part of this
once you understand the basics and why
you do these things you can't do it by
yourself right the only thing we are
saying is we have instead of need to
to use it to require
that competition out in
that conditional space
our
resource is cloud-based you cannot put
it on the cloud and go and do your thing
but every fundamental of each
bioinformatics are going in and it's
problematic too will be taught from the
basics in this course
thank you
i i also i i
use a lot of lineups i use a lot of
linux
but i i also understand that for each
biopharmatic tool you have to learn
probably dedicate two to three months to
learn each tool before you can begin to
work right we want
circumventing that now you can learn
you can continue doing your projects
as you learn you don't need to wait for
three months to understand how five
months when i start python for six
months to understand lineups before you
begin to work on a project right
we can learn as you practice that that's
our goal thank you very much
so i've been i've been saying a lot
about
this
t-bow server
t-bow server let me just go straight and
show us how it works for sure it's
basics
so i'll do that in a minute let me
okay nice to see my screen
yes we can okay so this is this is our
second platform
we call it the server t builder info
i'll put the link
also here so anybody can also go
straight to it right
i want to show you the
extent of this right
so this is the bow server right and you
can see
that it has a lot of options a lot of
functions
as long as you are dealing with negative
sequencing data
there is no function you can do on this
right this is transcriptomics
this is genomics and epigenetics this is
just working strictly on dna and analog
sequences if you want to work on
microrna this is metagenomics and
microbiome this is chime 2 for people
that are known metagenomics
right this is also you can also treat
your mass specifically data here you can
deal with proteomics or metabolomics
and
if you come to this side you can also
see that there are data mining and data
learning features right and all of these
can be done at just
the touch of the button right all you
need to do is just click on this
and and to take you to the next stage
one good thing about this one logistical
validity it is air enabled so once you
click on a pipeline it immediately gives
you options
right because i said there are plenty of
ways to analyze data but once you click
on the pipeline it automatically tells
you the next one or two steps to take
right
and
guide you until you reach the end of
that pipeline for example
let me
we and we also have demo data sets that
you can use
to learn right you can you can use this
today especially if you are not
registered
and yet you want to have a feel of this
of this platform you can use this big
data set right these are our realistic
pipelines
the the breadth consumption i was
talking about this is the pdx right if
you click on it
right you can see
bringing you to these sessions right and
if you check on here
all of these are what are bothermatic
algorithms i i won't like to go to them
because you know
as i said this is
this is like like a beginner program
some people might not have an idea
right but
if you are familiar it beats mathematics
you know that you will know that all
these tools
by themselves are the common mathematic
tools you have clean primer
pcl claim trigonometric
and instead of you running commands on
your lineups
and your python to be able to get this
response to this
all you need to do is just click for
example if i click on start like i want
to tags
don't waste time
please i'll start a pipeline right
here
you know what i said earlier
these are democracies they've been
imputed onto this right
so i just click ok
then
almost automatically you can see that
some
tools are highlighted in yellow and i
said this is air enabled ai guided it's
giving me options now out of all the
pluto our
tools the next one i need to use is any
of this right that's that's the bit of
it so if i just click on these two just
add this button
what the first night see it will explain
what that tool does
right the chromatic is a tool that is
used to trim
adapter sequences you should trim poor
quality widths on the sequence so it's
showing me what it does right and if i
click ok
it will do that action without me
pressing any commands right you can see
that
after clicking this
all that things are also being
highlighted here it's going to be pcl
click that's been aligned for people
that are familiar all these all these
steps will take during the course of
this program but i'll click on this pcl
claim i'm saying
clean the pcl duplicates that are
that are present in this sequence right
i'll click okay consider it showing me
other tools right and that's how it will
be able to guide you from one
performative to to another from here is
highlighting just
these three things right i can then
click on one or either of them to the
end of the pipeline right that's that's
the big thing about this and once i
click on it for example let me click on
this
so let me just click okay see for
everything i click it tells you what it
does
right
i go to the next one once i click on
this
it tells me what it does then i can end
the pipeline
right i want to end the pipeline what do
i do i i consider i continue my day i
don't need to wait for it to finish
some are immediate
some will take
time depending on what you're working on
right but that and that is it and i can
get my results without needing to have
conditional size of my system or have
the
expertise on how each of these things i
don't know how pcl clean works i just
click on it and it does its job i don't
know how traumatic works i need to know
what it does will teach you what it does
but i don't need to be so i don't have
an expert in cinematic
right and it does its job and i get my
results that way i'm i'm doing projects
i'm learning
and
i'm doing project i'm i'm i'm getting
answers i'm analyzing things right
that's the beauty thing about this
summer
info so starting from next program
networks day we teach you about the
thing to do of each what do you do with
genomics what
what functions do you click
what does pre-processing mean what does
mapping or genome mean what does mapping
in the transcript doing what do you mean
by differentiating expression right all
these tools and their functions at the
beginner level will expose you to it
right and i also like to post again and
ask are there questions before
we go on to this program per se i just
want you
questions
uh please if i may ask is it
instructor-led or it's um self-taught
like before only instructor led right
now i said it's more like an hybrid
session right
we'll have those additional resources
where you learn the basics fundamentals
self-paced right but on wednesdays who
come together right where
the
mentors dr toy and hai and other
international mentors will be able to
guide you through those sessions right
we'll do everything together here
everything everything we're talking
about we'll do it together in this
session we'll give you the video i will
be available all week either on whatsapp
or slack or true personal calls right
you ask us and guide you through it's
that's one of the advantages
it's meant to guide it when i learned
bioinformatics i didn't have a mentor i
i was literally everything
but when i joined pine bark
they are mentors
local mentors the international mentors
and they are all available at any point
in time on both our whatsapp and slash
channel just come and ask any question
somebody will answer you
and that's that
the the good part of it is every point
you have someone to ask a question about
a clarification
did that answer a question sir
hello sir
please
i still be on my
so it's mental guided it's it's
absolutely integrated and all our
mentors are available at any point in
time you can just just give us a call
shadow's opponent you can throw your
questions and what's up throw your
questions on
on
we're going to have a slack channel
where you can also ask questions
and
we'll answer your questions good luck
our mentors and regional mentors right
and as the other earlier speaker said
what if i want to do it myself what if i
don't want to use our platform and i'm
like okay
we also teach you the programs needed we
teach you how
from step by step we teach you python
these are the programs that you need to
do it by yourself right
those are also available on
our
learn platform another thing we also do
is for every session
you just
want to give your assignments
i will tell you what to do for example
there's a data assignment able to use
the fee you have assignments you can see
where they are for assignments right you
have to complete your profile like i
explained earlier
you have to explore the sovereignty
boundary if you're interested just send
us a message
at omixlogic
dot ngr at gmail.com
i'm typing it who sends you
a demo a demo
username
yes gifts homework yes
other dedication you you you'll be
tested
because i've said earlier it's part kind
zone this is not just theory there is no
theory in bioinformatics it's practical
engine right so
the assignment for today is already full
you have to complete your profile on the
platform you first talked about you have
to explore several info you said those
messages myself and alfred will send you
a demo
account right i just enter just click
around just walk around see what it does
free of charge you can use any of the
demo pipelines to test and see then we
already have to consider absolutely free
reduction of informatic costs
which um i'll try and
write the link again i think i put it
there already
another introduction to bytes and
multiples these are two courses
absolutely free and they are beginner
courses right by time for people that
register this is the first thing to ask
you next week when is that
oh boy
oh lady i hope you have done this right
so now to the program itself the
introduction to big data informatics
which i said earlier in six industry
sessions we're going to talk about
what's next generation sequencing what
is about statistics what is bigoted
analysis
right to be able to
learn about these module mix and learn
how
to apply them in solving questions in
your field right the first session
starts next week wednesday november 24th
exactly for example we're introduced to
big guitar in biology right
what's what started this data exclusion
sequencing
what are the what is the evolution of
sequence what are the generations the
first generation second direction
generation what
what are the steps needed for next
generation sequencing right then the
week after will talk about introduction
to genomics we'll talk about dna
variants mutations
what does it mean how do we how do we do
very uncalling what is somatic mutation
what is the
what what what does somatosnps
how do they characterize cancers or
molecular producers of cancer so talk
about codons amino acids what are genes
right they were able to visualize our
sequence right when you when
how do you even visualize it right this
is a picture of a visualization
website known as jeep cows right and how
do you understand
then later what how do you analyze this
genomic data right and i said i want to
show you the platform earlier so i will
teach you what each of this step means
what do we do in processing what do you
mean by mapping alignment what do you
mean by variance calling what do you
mean by annotation what do you mean by
the division of the ants calling how do
we understand analyze this how do they
help
in learning about or analyzing success
ability to infections
and diseases so that will be our second
topic
right then our first session will be
about trust terms of gene activity
analysis i'm sure from nuclear
biologists we know about the
the movement from dna to rna
to
proteins right the the total
mrna in in
in itself is known as transcriptome
because they are called mri transcripts
we understand how gene expression data
analysis
can help
in understanding diseases and infections
marks no problem we will send it just
drop your
email address as i said earlier just
send me a mail at comicslogic.ninja
gmail.com
the
recording will be available for all
right we also post it at our pine bowl
youtube channel you can also watch it
there and god we can send us a
message.ninja gmail.com so that this
will be our cut session
on
transylvanix right we'll teach you how
do you prepare data for analysis
right we also teach you how to make use
of this platform to understand
this as i said earlier our
ai guided platform is color coded to be
able to guide you to talking about the
next thing so
this is what we'll do in our thought
sessions so as i said we also show you
examples of the breast cancer cell lines
right why do we use cell lines when do
we use
when do we use tissues to understand
whatever we need right the next section
of that would be about differentiating
expression
where we use static approaches to study
and understand rna-seq after mapping
them to reference genome then our first
session will be on static analysis and
machine learning we use tata approaches
to study
the data we are getting from our gene
expression right we start finding
resources relationships to data
and collect data on different variables
and compare them
with the genetic expression data right
and we will teach how to get that done
then our last
well as a part of that we also teach you
data analysis in python
and how you can
visualize your sequence and our last
session will be introduction to bar
project right since i because of the
high cost of sequencing
how can i get these sequences how can i
get because most of these sequences are
being deposited at public depositories
when they are publicly available how do
i search for sequences if i'm working on
a how do i get sequencing data for a
how will i glean and how do i start to
analyze it to be able to gain
information for my own research that
would be what we'll end up with as i
said earlier on our platform
every
achievement
gets you points if you complete the
course from that point if you want a
pipeline on your point for the profile
and all these points added together
to
get you points and
which will get you certificates right so
this is this is
just a
rundown of our program the introduction
to big data informatics
that start next week wednesday
at this point i would love to post and
entertain more questions
hello hello everyone
hello yes i said i'd have questions
before we go straight to
the last thing we love to do today and
is registering you for the program
next week
any question
so to
first
to register for the program yes do i
need to
make the payments first before
before the registration
the
payment is actually registration for the
program before we add one report to
registration
to allow you part of this program
but to be part of the program itself you
have to demonstrations by payment for
that program
however
so i want to ask is there a way we can
pay
one of like from start to finish you pay
instead of paying in bids
oh no we don't well that's what i'm
saying i say for this program it's an
independent program
right this six weeks is an independent
program but is is more like a beginner
program right we plan to hold series of
programs later some are even as lasting
as three months program right so we feel
that it is it is more sensible it's it's
more economical to pay for the sales of
those programs right and
it depends on the number of participants
that will decide on
how how often they want to program
is it quarterly is it so for now i just
holding independent programs
just and so for now this program is a
standalone
right he will do it
it's
by the next program it could be another
level for this but this program is
standalone program for now yeah dr toya
and i are working on an exhaustive
comprehensive
semester like program when that is done
you can that's okay pay for three months
we'll teach you from a to z but for now
this is just an
independent beginner program
okay um i i would like that i will
register for this but
also i would also like that kind of
three more things so because
i just want to pay one off and you know
i'm focused on instead of i think i'll
stay prepared but yes
that i'm saying we will keep you updated
once since we have your contact details
you keep your little about all our
programs the beginner ones the advanced
intermediate one and what we have is
semester like us which we are working on
you also
also let you know about it
another question
for this course yes payment is that the
payment is registration
gift
the payment itself is the registration
so when you register you'll be let me
let's quickly go to the program page so
probably you understand
what i mean by that
so i'm putting the link here
so that you can see the
link page
sorry a minute
so this is so this is the
program website right where you come
here this is
where you get information about the
programs
right you get everything these are the
methods of faculty
this this gives you
this is more like the program syllabus
right and when you click on register
if it was before this program we had
this
more like a registration
page
for these free webinars right but now i
just want to register
please
i also put this on
the chat box
so the second one takes you straight to
the payment page
so i think my network is a bit slow i
apologize
okay so this is put payment this is the
program page too so when you click on
start your application
it gives you these options right
45 dollars
for this for most people
and it has all this right
if you want a size this if you want one
one one mental support you want us to
be putting you around and guiding you
all through you can pay for sixty
dollars or
this is if you want to that even after
this program you want us to assist you
with your project right you can pay this
for most participants which are for
beginners
you can pay the 45 dollars where you
click the select option depending on
what your preference is
so once you click on this it will open a
payment page
where you can impute your details
so i'll see my screen
yeah we can see
so you just put your email address which
you already opened with us
put your card details
and click on pay and
you'll be registered for the program
so once again let me
put this on the chat phone this is the
full
payment page
once you click on this it brings you
directly
to our payment page where you just click
on start your application
enter your credentials right start your
application
entire card details right after
selecting any option you want
and you're registered for the program
the program starts filling next week
wednesday we are going to have our
first session
i'm sorry sir i think it would be nice
if there's a slab channel immediately
where we can have this yeah for webster
participation we have a slack channel
where we for all participants we
actually have a whatsapp channel where
you can get more information about the
program for registered participants we
also have a slack channel
where we have them to that way
we can
you get questions
your
all our mentors
are headed
on that platform so as you're asking
questions local mentors international
mentors
they can assist you with your questions
right but we also have a whatsapp
channel which is just for all
participants this like for example this
video
we posted on that channel
right also we also emailed so we mix of
all available channels
to get our course information we have
whatsapp we have slack we also send
emails
so but
the informations and we also
ask you to i'll post on our on our sub
channels later also include your
indulgence to follow us on linkedin
instagram
and
on facebook
we have all this information where
we put it in fact i remember from the
people that were just
deep registration i sent them what's up
links to join our awesome but for the
registered members who send them a slack
channel ready
they can join but strictly for
registered participants
any more questions
any more questions
so i'm also
putting a whatsapp link
on this chat forum so you can just click
and join our whatsapp group
and
you'll get more information from it
as i said earlier you can contact us at
comicslogic.org
ngl at
gmail.com
we'll answer all your questions
there are more questions i would love to
answer if they're not love to thank you
for being part of us today no you don't
have to pay today you have to next week
wednesday
to pay
yes you can pay before next session
please you can't pay for next session
gladly and even after the next session
you can pay for the concession we'll
send you the video session video what
you have missed and we can start from
there
so you still have opportunity to pay
before the next session or the first
second session
you stop accepting after second session
only because as i said is a culturally
comprehensive program we don't want to
strike
people that will be able to work with us
alone so you have to you have a chance
to get to second session
right
if there are no more questions it's
it's been an eventful evening i'm really
elated i thank everyone that's come for
this program
for
the time spread with us for indulgence
for your questions i hope you
will be part of this program and we can
create
life scientists
greetings from myself from alfred aquila
and from pineal tech
in nigeria
globally
we'll make sure to send the videos over
to you for this session and respect to
the part of this program thank you very
much
and we'll see you soon
you